[Musik]
die gäste harald mit der firma bin vom
dienstgrad stadtmeister und beim walzer
und 14
als unteroffizier für
öffentlichkeitsarbeit und kommunikation
eingesetzt
ja stets für öffentlichkeitsarbeit
unsere aufgabe ist die kommunikation und
zur bevölkerung
wir nutzen dazu vor allem die sozialen
netzwerke und unsere guten zeiten und
sind dabei direkt ein paar teams konnten
unterstellt
[Musik]
während der übung handwerk 19 problemlos
platz einstieg ist es unsere aufgabe die
union zu dokumentieren dazu unterstützen
mich milizsoldaten die privaten
fernsehsender betreiben unterstellen wir
professionell videos
[Musik]